thank you and hello everyone uh last
second and the the slides are up uh
great I was a little afraid
all right so um yeah today I'm going to
talk about specifying Behavior with
protocols type classes and trades so
that's quite a mouthful right and uh not
only that but we have three languages
ahead of us so
um let's better get started
um I'm colia in my day-to-day work I'm
doing a data and machine learning
engineering at innovix I'm a Python's
Ghana Enthusiast but as you might notice
from the first slide I also like rust
and behavior so this is the first big
word let's say in this rather long title
what what do I mean by Behavior this is
like a big word on its own so let's
maybe scope it down for this talk a
little and I thought about it and uh one
angle or one one perspective you could
go about is basically talking about the
what and the how now another two big
words what do I mean by that
um what I mean is basically like
specifying the behavior so we can think
of what an object or system should be
able to do for example walking and
walking and yes duct typing will come
soon
and the other side of the coin basically
would be the how like how do we want to
implement this Behavior right and I
promise you we will see some more Ducks
down the road
and coming back to walking now I'm no
biologist but probably like a normal
walking pattern maybe of a duck could be
something like this left right left
right and so on but of course
implementing the walk like the what we
specified what should be able what
should the duck be able to do
could also be in theory different of
course right we could make the duck hop
and this is exactly where we also gonna
be focusing within this talk so we're
gonna focus on the how and especially
we're gonna scoping to typing the
protocols trades in the westward and
also type classes in Scala
so
um more duct typing
probably you all heard this quote but I
will read it anyways if it walks like a
duck and it quarks like a duck then it
must be a duck so coming from this
specification we just talked about if
both requirements are met then we
basically can assume that it indeed is a
duck now this is still like a little
abstract right what what does this mean
even so maybe let's have a look at the
concrete example and you can of course
not only find ducks in that sense for
maybe data classes that are called Ducks
but also for more primitive types so
let's have a look at this double method
on on the left where we basically get
any object X in there any uh and and
multiply it by two basically so in a
sense as you see from line four
to line line seven in a sense it's
somewhat of a numeric duck right because
we can call this this function on any of
these numeric types whether it's an
integer float or a complex number so
um and behind the scenes of course we
have the dunder mule method implemented
that's why why it's actually working but
um yeah so this is also a form of duct
typing
um but
if we if we like go to use cases out
there in the wild we we don't have
Primitives only as you all probably know
on your data projects but we rather have
like more complex types for example here
this data class person which has a name
and H and we can of course also
instantiate this one to Jane with 30 and
if we now try to call this a double
method
the very same double method on Jane
of course we expect that it runs at uh
that it fails at runtime
so no safety on on that side basically
so what did we see so far it's a very
powerful I think and flexible concept of
stuck typing because we can just we
somewhat assume
um yeah that some variable has a
property but as we also saw for this
example on the left
it's not possible to to get this uh
static type safety let's say where we
would earlier be noticed that something
will not will not work
so um we will see in a sec how we uh how
we can go about this and improve on
there but for the rest of this talk uh
we will we will
um we will focus on a specific behavior
I talked about behavior
um lots of times now so let's make it
more concrete and we want to implement
the so-called repeatable Behavior which
basically means I can have any sort of
object whether it's here A number that I
just repeat down the line so of course
this is like a very simple example or we
can do it with ducks or persons or
whatever whatever but it's a very good
example still to to just visualize the
the powerful
mechanic mechanisms Behind These Behind
These Concepts so whenever we have any
any thing like a number or a duck we
would call repeat and then get the get
the corresponding output
so now we just had a look at the plane
duct typing and now we want to enter
typing.protocol which is the static duct
typing so if you remember a few slides
back we had the
um not so cool property that we could
not check uh what's going on at uh yeah
before runtime basically and uh typing
um the protocol exactly focuses this
area
so what do we have here we first and
first in the first line we specify a
typewr like basically a generic variable
right we want to as we just saw the the
slide before we want to be able to throw
in uh everything we just have this
generic Behavior
and the key thing for typing the
protocol is that we yeah that we just
specified in the brackets like basically
inheritance and this makes whatever
class uh we uh we we're writing down
here this makes it a repeatable and in
that case it's the repeatable protocol
which has a method uh that basically
just uh yeah takes on repeat count and
then Returns the list and also notice we
don't have any implementation here right
because we we want to enhance basically
the other types to implement
um whatever they feel like is repeatable
for them right um remember
or duck walking patterns from few slides
back where basically maybe some duck
wants to to hop on the other wants to
walk differently
so back to our double method looks a
little different now but not really that
much different right we we have some
some X that we get as an input which is
further specified and this is with
another type VAR because we want to with
this we want to express it's at least an
repeatable but you can imagine if you if
you insert a person in there for x
it still should have the um the original
Behavior as well so imagine if you have
like a person which has other methods we
not only want to return any object that
only supports repeat afterwards but
which also uh so so to say persists the
original Behavior
this is why we need the second typo here
and now let's let's also make it more
concrete again with our person this is
also really nice you can now see from
from line 11 where we basically the data
class stays the same and we don't have
any like class hierarchy or whatnot so
basically we just specify for this type
or for this data class what repeat means
and of course I don't expect also for
the other example some
confusing implementations I just wanted
to keep it this is like just the detail
I I rather want your focus at the at the
protocol and the other mechanisms that
we will see later on so um yeah this is
basically then I think I also have it
here yeah right this is like an implicit
repeatable right because we without
specifying any anything else within this
data class we now have the capabilities
of repeatable and the uh not compiler
but we will we will see before run time
that actually this object also holds and
is of of type repeatable
maybe later sorry I'm
later please but I'm I'm just and
preferably by a slido
short on time sorry
okay so for a summary
um what did we say I also mentioned it
we don't have class hierarchies which is
great because as we will also see later
those Concepts like repeatable or also
serializable they rather form a
different hierarchy and you probably
don't necessarily want to mix them up
with your actual domain hierarchy
we have a static type checks so you can
use pylons or my Pi whatever this will
work all with a typical protocol and
warn you
and we have this flexible way of
assembling Concepts right I think not
only about repeatable but many other
behaviors that you can specify and then
just assemble in a very powerful and
modular way
um the things that made me a little
thinking uh was the Clutter and classes
and trivas what do I mean by that
um if you if we go back here we have the
um the repeat method basically bound to
our data class in other languages we
will see in a sec we have them rather
separated out where we do where we only
have like data definition and then uh um
Behavior definition and the other thing
is we have a little clutter with the
um Thai verse maybe so we at least
Define them in two two places but I
think this is just like getting used to
it and so
just uh yeah a general observation Maybe
um so right how do other language
languages solve this but first
um two interesting quotes I I found
um
which the first one is use Python
protocol to Define implicit interfaces
and the second one is a protocol is a
special case of ABC which works
implicitly so implicit I think I've
heard that before maybe you too
from Scala they're of course this comes
from Scala like we there's a lot of
implicits and uh there's this shared is
about implicit pleasure Pleasures but I
definitely also
um so the other side where it's not so
much pleasure but before we come to to
Scala let's actually have a look at rust
so um again same idea we want to specify
behavior and we want to concretely
specify the repeatable
how do we do this in in Rust is
basically Define a trade and just from
the first glance I think it already
looks quite similar like we have this uh
repeatable thing here it's called a
trade it's not a class and it has some
function some method in it right which
takes repeat count and returns in this
case a vector of self and this is
actually a rather important detail I
will show that later on but from the
general
um yeah generally it looks quite similar
of course this index and rust is rather
different with borrowing Concepts and
also references but it uh yeah somehow
looks quite quite similar
and one bigger difference is also in
line five where we basically have our
double function again and we also
specify right we want to specify this
type we we don't expect this type to be
any generic but we wanted to to specify
that it's of repeatable so that we have
this super capabilities of repeating
something
and uh this is also as you see tied to
the to the very method so we are not
defining the type VAR outside of this
function
and for the implementing for
implementing this protocol it's also or
a trade in that case it's also slightly
different where we first in line 9
Define the data
data representation also person also
nothing fancy but in line 14
it's actually
um where where it's more interesting
because here we really see that the
implementation is not within the data
class basically right
and of course also here the
um
the the syntax is slightly different
and now I promise you to to talk a
little about the self-type which is
pretty
um interesting because as you remember
from the python implementation we had
this generic right where we where we
would say Hey you of course want to do
it for every uh um type basically or you
want to be generic that's what generics
are all about it in the end rust has a
pretty cool idea of having this
self-type where you basically say
whoever implements the repeatable
protocol or trade will be returned as
well so here in the red box I have it I
wrote it down explicitly itself but you
could as well replace it with person so
with the struct that we defined above
same implementation
all right uh calling and instantiation
it is not really
um that interesting so I will skip that
one we will just create Jane with age 30
and then double it
all right so let's have a um
short side by side comparison
where we basically now see again how
similar they they really look like
um so the self-type is of course a
little more specific to rust right and
on the right hand we see the python code
where we Define in line one the the type
bar not needed in in Rust at that point
and also as I already already mentioned
we are not implementing the repeat
method within the data class as we do it
in Python on the right side but we
rather have it outside right so our
person data class or struct in that case
really stays as it is
um yeah here I think I also mentioned
the most important points so basically
in rust on the left side
excuse me we specify the T the variable
at hand really tied to the the method
and on your right we we again have this
concept of specifying the type type R
outside
all right so Scala three we have another
language whoa uh Running Out of Time
slowly so let's go about it Scala three
you must know
um it's uh there's a huge difference to
Scala 2 mainly if you saw syntax
examples um there are no curly places
braces if you wish and uh yeah looks a
lot more similar to python actually
which is great I think so um
in line one we already see some
commonality between rust and Scala we
have even the same keyword which is
called trade but we have the generic
back also as on python right we have
this generic variable
the rest really is the same I think at
that point I I don't even need to go
about it in detail once more let's have
a short look at the Double method down
in in line eight where we again also
similar to rust where we specify our
type at hand to be of type repeatable
actually behind the scenes the compiler
will search for any implicit
implementation for the repeated
repeatable type for that t so maybe we
defined some implicit I will show you in
a sec for person so the compiler will
resolve it compared him
there's a little trick I um I I uh I was
hiding from you so far which is the
extension method this is uh needed in
Scala it's slightly officiating or
confusing but what it does in the end is
that you can call this dot repeat method
as we do it in line 9 on any object so
this is basically just an extension
method right you want to call this
method on on any any object basically
okay
um the rest also looks uh astonishingly
similar I would say so we have in in
Scala we have the concept of case class
which is basically data class slash
structs where we again Define name and
age for the person
and now this implicit definition and
line 13 starts so you also must know in
scalar three there is actually no
implicits at least they are not caught
like this they are called Givens or the
syntax has changed a little so what we
do here is a little similar to what what
we did in Rust we will also see that
side by side in a sec where we basically
say we have a given repeatable for that
person type and this then again has some
more or less arbitrary implementation
so side by side
um left we have the Scala word that we
just uh um saw and on the right we have
the uh rust rust board
as we already saw as I mentioned earlier
we have even the same keyword which is
trade and also the interface in general
looks pretty similar right we we just
have this repeat method
then of course the extension part is a
little more confusing on the Escala or a
little more code at least on the Scala
side then for the implementation part
also pretty similar I would say as I
just mentioned we have this given
repeatable of person on the Scala side
on the left side
and on the right hand side we have the
implementation repeatable for person
right so and there again we can make use
of this self-type where we basically
don't need to specify the
parameter further
all right double method also really
similar basically the only major thing
is really syntax I would say we have
some other form of braces here and also
referencing and rust
then this brings me actually to the
summary
so uh what did we see we um we spent
most of our time having a look at these
three concepts but they all have I would
say the main uh the same main idea which
is basically enhancing your types with
uh arbitrary Behavior we saw this for a
repeatable
and yeah this is in general I would say
a very powerful mechanism to abstract
and modernize over those Concepts and I
put some more examples here serializable
clonable
where you can clone stuff showable where
you can print I think this one is is
from rust relies on that one if I'm not
mistaken a releaseable where you maybe
have some resources that needs to be
safely released when when opening it
opening a file and then closing it right
some ordering where you want to have
some arbitrary type where you want to
give the capability that it's uh yeah
basically that you can sort it or you
can even take it to to some level of
monets where you yeah where you
basically Define these behaviors
for the respective types
another really interesting thing I
observed is that languages in general
tend from my observations or at least
for this very specific mechanism
mechanics they're moving towards each
other right we saw that Scala is really
moving towards the indentation part of
python python maybe is looking more and
more into things like like typing and
rust is somewhere in between which of
course has the great opportunity to take
the best of all words and yeah this is
was really interesting to me
and um yeah maybe the the last reminder
all roads lead to to Rome right so uh
pick the most pragmatic solution I would
say so I think
please don't start maybe with monets and
type classes in in every project
it's very yeah I think there's many many
other
um
features in the language that are way
more important
all right so I have prepared some code
for this talk
feel free to to scan this QR code and
otherwise I'm happy to to talk to you
also at our innovex booth if you can can
find me there and uh yeah thank you and
now now it's the part for the question I
hope yours will be answered as well
[Applause]
thank you very much
and we already have a couple of
questions which is great because we have
seven minutes left so we can fit a lot
in these seven minutes I guess
um and the first question is what is
your take on explicit is better than
implicit by using protocol and python
are you hiding a contract you want to
ideally enforce
can you repeat the first one now I
forgot the first part but maybe let's
take the the first you take on explicit
versus implicit okay yeah yeah explicit
versus implicit so um this is maybe
really resembles the last Point um I I
talked about basically all roads lead to
Rome
and I um to be honest at least starting
something I always prefer explicit
because this just also maybe from the
code examples you see it's just another
concept also slightly different syntax
you need to to teach yourself but also
your team so this is of course
um yeah some some
Next Level let's say or some some
slightly fancier concept so I would
prefer that personally for the first
step
but these concepts are really powerful
if you're like code based grows and
grows because you can really in the end
um
just add for a new type the new
implementation and it will just work
which is great which might not be so
easy if you do it explicitly now the
second part second part of the question
was
quote by using protocol and python
you're hiding a contract you want to
ideally enforce
that's how it's formulated here
okay that one I don't really get but if
the is the person in here by any chance
and wants to elaborate
can you wait a second let me give you
the mic otherwise the people online are
completely left out
hi so I'm not the person who has the
question but I I think I have an idea
what this means so basically in Python
when you have the definition of the data
class you don't have any let's say link
that tells you there's a protocol
defined for that for that method and
that can lead to rather dangerous paths
totally agree and
also a very good observation actually I
think this is true definitely but as you
saw for example in this double method we
had at least have like some form of
security at least in the method itself
you have some guarantees that here I
really await or expect this this thing
to be of repeatable or whatever else but
in the data class itself totally yes
you're you're this is also of course a
great benefit because you're not tied
explicitly to this uh to this concept
but yeah good point thank you
then we have another question trades in
Rust and Scala allow adding
functionality to existing classes does
this work with python protocols
another great catch I
I didn't find a way to do it to be
honest if any one of you knows please
reach out to me I'm also the person
asking maybe if you're online feel free
to to check out my code and and comment
there on GitHub I would be very
interested
the next most upvoted question is could
you please explain why we
are why RT is needed in Python sure
maybe we can go back to this example
because it's
better to visualize here
so um yes so first we have this type of
our
T in line one this is not the one you're
talking about but here we basically
generic on the on the repeat method
itself but in Python we also need
another declaration or another type bar
for the bound of repeatable only let's
say this double method if I would only
put X in here of like a replace RT with
product with repeatable then and also
returning repeatable then I would really
only limit myself or the implementation
to be of repeatable so everything this
method would return is only something
that has a repeat method but you can
imagine if you if you as like if you
have like a person type and this has a
bunch of other methods on it then you
want to persist those methods as well
right so you don't want to lose them
this is the reasoning
but isn't sufficient to write
a repeatable after it's cold really
sorry
why do I need Type 4 here why it's not
sufficient to write X column repeatable
this is exactly the thing so if you
would only write repeatable then you
would limit yourself to really only this
protocol right you would only uh have
something returned that has that can
only repeat but maybe it loses all the
other properties
okay I have another question
why should the empty python protocol
what should the empty python protocol
method return
raise not Implement an error
[Music]
good point yeah could be I mean you can
probably
um
return anything there but the thing is
the repeatable protocol itself stands
for itself so as long as you don't
implement it
it will also not not give you anything
of like not implemented error but if you
of course implement it for a person and
then still have dot dot then you could
run into into these uh there also I
guess
okay then thank you so much for this
very interesting talk I'm afraid we're
running out of time I guess you'll be
available in the for you for further
questions definitely
thank you
[Applause]